monsieur gallien bonjour merci d'être
avec nous en direct
nous avons tous suivi l'allocution du
chef de l'état hier soir et puis les
mesures drastiques 1 qui ont été
présentés détaillé par le ministre de
l'intérieur
christophe castaner on sait que les
écoles les universités tout est fermé
depuis déjà quelques jours quel impact
cela va-t-il avoir sur les étudiants et
notamment les concours qui doivent se
dérouler prochainement
écoutez il ya semble-t-il une mesure de
gel est en tout cas de sinon
d'annulation pour la période qui vient
donc de report je pense que ça c'est une
partie des sujets là là l'enjeu est
effectivement et apport de bloquer de
limiter au maximum les contacts et donc
forcément on peut pas imaginer un seul
instant que ce genre d'opération puisse
se tenir comme d'autres comme d'autres
événements qui regroupe un certain
nombre de personnes je pense aux
événements culturels ou économiques
c'est évident que ces choses là doivent
être suspendues et repoussé papa d'être
d'état des semaines qui viennent la
prochaine restaurant plus que les que
les mesures prises puissent faire
baisser large e10 est là le caractère du
script défi menace de ce virus
alors on l'a vu un récemment les
enseignants les professeurs étaient dans
la rue mobilisés ces derniers temps
contre le projet de la réforme des
retraites également par rapport au
manque de moyens est le chef de l'état
qui a annoncé hier la suspension pour un
moment de cette réforme
comment est ce que vous avez réagi tout
d'abord à cette annonce est ce que vous
pensez que finalement cette réforme peut
survivre ou est-ce que coco vite 19 ou
est ce qu'elle va justement être renvoyé
à jamais et finalement je vais je
au jour d'aujourd'hui c'est vraiment un
sujet qui nous échappe complètement
tout le monde est concentré sur
l'essentiel cette affaire il ya les
mêmes indications on dirait que les
mesures qui sont longs et les prix
soient prises beaucoup plus rapidement
un peu le sens de mes interventions
récentes partout sur les sauts les
médias je crois que lui ni d un
éducateur renseignements vhc c'est
quelque chose de très important
maintenant
alors jeune allemand devient un enjeu
national un enjeu européen international
et donc forcément je chacun d'entre eux
doit être mobilisés chacun d'entre nous
doit être quelque part laissé de côté
les jours 10 210 un corporatisme et
actions largement déjà bloqué le pays
dans des semaines je dirais aux bas
avant donc c'est fait c'est un atout
notre moment et je pense que
effectivement les semaines qui viendront
après les recettes de reconquête et
j'espère qu'à 48 possibles seront celles
aussi de d'une pacification du climat
qui était dès qu'ils étaient un petit
peu de temps auparavant
emmanuel macron adopté un ton plutôt
martial hier à six reprises il a martelé
nous sommes en guerre une mobilisation
qui doit être nationale c'est l'unité
qui doit prévaloir aujourd'hui en france
pour justement faire face à cette
pandémie alors là c'est le point
important bon d'accord on se lance ici
si vous le souhaitez c'est un point qui
doit être absolument essentiel terre que
d'abord il faut de la cohérence de la
cohérence qui doit être au plus haut
niveau de l'état au niveau européen au
niveau international mais d'abord dit
chez nous au niveau national ce week-end
sitôt tremblant ces dernières semaines
et la maman je pense car enfin de la
cohérence et de la clarté dont cohérence
clarté il faut de la clarté parce que
finalement on se rend bien compte que
pour que l'ensemble de la population
soit embarqué dans cet effort il faut
beaucoup de clarté beaucoup de cohérence
et aussi de la fermeté on ressent
vraiment monté de la fermeté c'est dit
c'est normal il est lui-même fallu que
cette fermeté vient un peu plus tôt de
mon point de vue je militais depuis un
certain temps de deux jours alors
évidemment on est surtout là où on peu
sonné sur même une espèce de visuels
pour qu' il y ait encore une fois une
prise en compte beaucoup plus faire
beaucoup plus rapide des ce qui est
essentiel c'est ce qu'on appelle le
confinement ce qui était à peine cité
hier métier qu'est ce qui était qui et
élémentaires pour deux raisons d'abord
pour ce que parce que seront salutaires
c'est essentiel sur le plan sanitaire
c'est la seule mesure aujourd'hui avec
des équipements qui font défaut en
france les masques les gants espérons
que ça va arriver et évidemment le fait
tester les gens et puis le deuxième
point c'est aussi un point essentiel
pour que la période pourquoi une fois de
gel de l'activité des slicks y
d'activités économiques de paralyser
d'accueil économique soit la plus courte
possible parce qu'on voit bien maman que
l'enjeu il est aussi de récupérer plus
vite possible sur le plan économique il
savait très compliqué donc plus on
accélère la capacité de l'utr de guerre
contentieux virus plus on est en
capacité de reprendre économiquement et
ça va être le ça va être tout de suite
et c'est déjà tout de suite le niveau
quasi essentiel de ce qui est à venir en
terme de combat c'est d'ailleurs le
ministre de l'intérieur qui a été
beaucoup plus clair dans ses
explications a reproché justement à
emmanuel ma content de ne pas avoir
employé par exemple le mans confinement
est ce que c'était justement
au ministre de l'intérieur de de monter
vraiment à l'avant et que et que le
discours en fait du chef de l'état
n'essayez pas de créer une panique au
sein de la population
il ya peut-être un peu ça moi je moi je
reste persuadé qu'il faut que ce soit
cohérent il ya déjà quelques jours voir
un peu auparavant c'est à emmanuel
macron temps plein c'est le gouvernement
nous autorise t il et qui aurait pu être
plus clair plus plus plus ferme
c'est un fait la fermeté j'irai
politique négative c'est la parité
politique positive chère qu'en gros on
est tous embarqués sur un bateau qui
tempête terrible et il faut à ce moment
là effectivement on choisit son album
sera tournée vers un comité scientifique
tout le temps dans ton parfois eux-mêmes
doit avoir des doutes c'est évidemment
prendre des avis les redonnais il faut
dégainer plus rapidement watts et pato
au tour d'italie qui ont déjà été passés
entre idées et mesure compliqué mais on
voit aussi d'autres qui en asie ont pris
les mesures parfois de nature différente
on pouvait s'inspirer après on n'a pas
toujours forcément négativement mais qui
ont pu qui ont pu traverser cette crise
plus facilement et qui n'a lançant dans
un réseau beaucoup plus calme donc il
nous faut ce capitaine il nous faut ce
capitaine ferme
jirel et évidemment il est entouré c'est
très bien ça montre que chacun peut
jouer son rôle maintenant
encore une fois nos critiques ont plu
soignants dans la dans la capacité
d'agir n'est tout ce qui a été dit mais
encore une fois les minutes comptent
pour des heures les autres camps pour
des journées les journées contours des
semaines en plus on perd deux minutes
aujourd'hui c'est parce qu'un pas en
seconde plus on est dans la difficulté à
venir et donc je crois qu'il est
essentiel maman quelque chose soit
affirme appliquer avec grande fermeté et
grande fermeté veut pas dire pour autant
encore une fois qu'on en abandonne
évidemment l'univers démocratique dans
lequel nous vivons
ça n'a rien à voir c'est quelque chose
qui permet de lutter efficacement on l'a
vu partout contre ce terrible virus et
ses conséquences sanitaires mais surtout
économique et social pour nous si
beaucoup en tout cas jean christophe
gallien d'avoir répondu à nos questions
je rappelle que vous êtes enseignant à
l'université paris sorbonne